I am a middle school student from
Washington state,
as you already know,
our environment is threatened by human
right now and it's time to make a
change,
but a lot of people don't see this rack
or they don't want to make a change.
The question is,
how can we get to influence human to
protect the planet in order,
something important actions we can do
starting right now to save the world.
I know it's hard,
but I just hope that you could give me
some clue.
Thank you very much.
Victoria.
Victoria,
you are,
uh,
the key to the future,
my friend.
So here's the thing,
you're living in Washington state.
You know,
I lived in Seattle for many years.
I love Washington.
Go seahawks.
I'm right there,
my friend.
Go Mariners.
Now you are in middle school.
You are the future.
People will tell you that,
but they're not kidding.
So what we want you to do is influence
your parents and make sure they vote.
Voting is the most important thing for
us,
especially this year.
And I want your parents.
I want you to encourage your parents to
take the environment into account when
they picked people to vote for.
Now you're a governor.
Jay inslee's,
an acquaintance of mine,
and he's a big environmental issue and
he wrote a book Apollo's fire and so on.
It's about the future,
but people are doing to take care of the
environment and have energy produced
electricity,
especially renewably without having to
burn fossil fuels.
So it's,
it's up to you to influence your
parents.
Yes,
very important to recycle your plastic
and your paper.
Very important to uh,
and also in Washington state.
I'm not sure exactly where you live,
but you can recycle your food waste
along with your yard waste.
And that becomes compost,
which nurses nourishes our farms,
which in turn produces food part of the
mythic cycle of life.
So you can encourage your parents to do
that,
but we need big ideas,
big changes we need in Washington state.
There's enormous opportunities for wind,
turbans and enormous opportunities for
photovoltaics,
for solar cells that takes sunlight and
make it right into electricity,
especially in eastern Washington.
So you can be part of that and you're in
middle school,
there was a turning point for most
people in their science education.
So I hope you Victoria will apply
yourself in science class and biology,
physics,
chemistry,
and there's probably another class you
might have about a planetary science or
astronomy and earth science.
And the other thing Victoria is really
important,
especially for girls is Algebra a and I
just want to tell you Algebra is this,
this way to think.
It trains your brain to think in this
way that enables you to imagine
to imagine things to,
to accept that you don't know the
answer,
but you're going to find it.
And so,
um,
I really encourage you,
I just tell you that I took Algebra.
You just have to practice.
There's no way around it.
You just gotTa do it over and over to
you to get comfortable with it.
And you can do it.
And by the way,
when you're a girl
in middle school,
you're kind of better at everything than
the boys.
Now that'll change in the next four or
five years.
I mean,
you'll even out,
but right now,
just go with it,
my friend.
Go with it.
Make sure you learn Algebra and learn
science so that you,
if you choose to be a scientist or
better yet an engineer,
which is a profession in which you use
science to solve problems and make
things that you can lead the world in
these new technologies,
but right now,
uh,
do those things at home that make that,
make an important difference at home
recycling and not wasting energy,
not wasting clean water.
And make sure your parents take the
environment into account and make sure
they vote.
Thank you Victoria.
Go get them.